things you need to know about this
iPhone 10's max review number one i'm
joanna stern i've got fairly small hands
and I don't love large phones
I'm also five six and a Wall Street
Journal tech columnist number two this
is George marish on and he's got well
bigger hands and loves bigger phones
he's seven seven and holds the record
for the tallest player in the history of
the NBA you also may recognize him from
the greatest movie of all time my giant
so what does this have to do with an
iphone yeah what I'm doing yeah I'm not
really sure actually the bigger iphone
10's max has a giant 6.5 inch screen a
giant battery and yes a giant price tag
it's basically the George marathon of
phones which actually would have been a
better name for the phone yeah the new
iPhone doesn't look that big in his
hands just look at how much handy has
left there but in mine it looks well max
I've got no hands and if you decide to
go big is there any real benefit over
the 10 s which is nearly identical but
smaller George has been helping me test
to find out hey thirty what's know about
George Morris on here's what I found
[Music]
the most impressive thing about the
design of the max is that big beautiful
OLED display it stretches to the edges
so there's no big frame like you had
with those older 5.5 inch iPhone plus
models it means more screen in the same
size package as one of those phones
everything from playing games to taking
photos is more immersive but with the
Macs
it's much harder for me at least to
reach things on the other side of the
screen one-handed C if I want to reach
for this weather app up here the
struggle is real it's sort of like this
for George on the other hand it's a
simple tap one-handed typing is also
hard for me Apple does have this feature
that shifts the screen down by swiping
on the line here
Samsung's Galaxy Note 9 with a similar
six point four inch screen at least
takes advantage of the extra space with
the note 9 you can put apps side-by-side
or shrink down a video and watch it
while you do something else the iPhone
has none of that if there's one reason
to go big though its battery life just
like George's got longer arms the 10s
max has a longer battery life than the
10s in my tests the 10s max lasted at
least an hour longer during the day I
didn't worry about my phone dying by
evening nearly as much as I do with my
ten in my streaming video test the 10s
max lasted nearly 13 hours the 10s
lasted 10 and a half
both the 10s and the 10s max have the
same improved cameras and camera
features I shot around with George to
test them my favourite improvement is
the ability to adjust the focus depth
after taking a photo in portrait mode
see here the ball isn't focused but
George is not but by adjusting the
f-stop I can bring him into focus if I
want the new smart HDR really does show
when taking shots with movement or in
some more complex lighting situations
it's better than the 10 but not worth
upgrading for that's for sure where I
really see the improvement over the 10
however is in the speed of the autofocus
and even launching the camera so you
don't miss shots like this so do you go
10s max well put your hand up to mine or
to the screen is your hand bigger than
this but okay maybe still smaller than
this sure then go for it
hey city so I buy this phone city